tout au long de la semaine en
partenariat avec Radio sensation nouveau
proposons de vivre le Festival de Cannes
des yvelinois Nicolas kirilovitz a
rencontré aujourd'hui un jeune
réalisateur qui fait ses débuts au Short
Film Corner cela fait désormais 9 ans
que le Festival de Cannes dédié un
espace réservé uniquement au
court-métrage le Short Film Corner cette
année près de 2000 réalisations sont
visionnables par tous les festivaliers
une exposition formidable pour les
jeunes réalisateurs comme Quentin Dupuy
Annie Blinois de 22 ans qui présente son
premier court-métrage le temps d'un
repas
c'est fini
à ton retour
merci à tous les deux
c'est compliqué pour tout le monde c'est
juste que des fois
le temps d'un repas c'est l'histoire
presque banale d'une soirée au
restaurant on découvre la vie et les
projets des personnages en train de
dîner plus de détails avec Quentin Dupuy
c'est un film que j'ai écrit produit
réalisé c'est 9 minutes donc c'est un
petit court-métrage ça se passe dans un
restaurant une seule nuit et on passe de
table en table on découvre tout ce qui
peut se passer une séance d'un
restaurant en fait tous les secrets qui
peuvent se dévoiler tout ce qui peut
tout ce qui peut changer en une seule
nuit dans le même endroit donc dans un
restaurant naturellement Quentin n'est
pas venu sur la Croisette pour profiter
uniquement des célèbres soirées
cannoises s'il est venu présenter son
film au Short Film Corner c'est pour
rencontrer des professionnels
expérimentés étoffer son carnet
d'adresses et prendre des contacts c'est
une super opportunité en fait pour nous
aujourd'hui de pouvoir parler du film de
pouvoir projeter on a une projection
aujourd'hui à 4h par exemple des procès
qui peuvent venir le voir et l'idée
c'est de pouvoir devoir la trouver des
rencontres rencontrer des acheteurs des
producteurs et de créer son réseau de
cette façon là en fait c'est vraiment
une bonne exposition par rapport à ça et
après une semaine de présence à Cannes
quent
in j'ai pas mal de retour quand même et
vraiment content les gens sont vraiment
appréciés bon retour donc ça fait assez
ça fait vraiment plaisir de pouvoir
avoir tout ça quent le rêve désormais
d'une carrière à la Guillaume Canet et
Jean Dujardin des stars internationales
qui comme lui ont grandi à plaisir c'est
vrai que ça fait rêver déjà
et c'est quand on va le parcours
international de Guillaume Canet dont du
jardin c'est vraiment un peu le rêve je
pense pour beaucoup de cinéastes
notamment pour moi de pouvoir se dire
qu'avant une carrière est vraiment
internationale dans France que dans les
pays anglo-saxons aux États-Unis c'est
vrai que c'est un peu le un peu le rêve
avec son BTS audiovisuel en poche et une
formation de comédien Quentin Dupuis a
pour projet de réaliser de nouveaux
courts-métrages cette fois-ci sur la
forme de série humoristique mais son
rêve ultime c'est de faire un
long-métrage
un reportage de radio sensation qui
proposera sur son antenne une émission
spéciale un zeste d'info depuis le
festival ce dimanche 26 mai à partir de
19h je vous le disais le Festival de
Cannes au début de cette édition pour
les Yvelinois c'est aussi Guillaume
Canet qui est venu présenter son premier
film américain hier avec notamment Clive
Owen blood Tyson remake des liens du
sang de Jacques Maillot et puis autre
yvelinois le trappiste Jamel Debbouze
également présent sur la Croisette hier
pour aimer quelque part où il campe un
second rôle il y est question d'un jeune
français de 26 ans qui doit aller en
Algérie pour sauver la maison de son
père extrait de la bande-annonce
je parle même pas l'arabe
c'est un pays riche Algérie
vendredi à Paris pour la finale du
trophée d'improvisation culture et
diversité portée par la compagnie de
Trappes Déclic Théâtre dont il est
d'ailleurs issu des jeunes de Trappes
seront opposés à ceux de Bordeaux l'île
et Rochefort nous en parlerons lors de
notre prochaine édition de